uh tonight governor christie gnome
tweeting at joe biden uh south dakota
will stand up and to defend freedom joe
biden we'll see you in court south
dakota governor christine is with us
governor um
well you were one of the first we got
greg abbott we got oklahoma we got
florida we got a lot of states right
behind you and as one of the first
comments i said after his comments on my
radio show was
this is headed straight to court and
it's not going to hold in my opinion
yeah you're exactly right sean i think
we have 14 different governors that have
now said they will take some kind of
action as for south dakota i'll fight to
protect my people and to defend their
freedoms in fact it shocked me that the
president actually said in his speech
today that this wasn't about freedom and
personal choice at all which i think is
indicative of what's really in his heart
and his agenda that he's got for this
country listen uh this is not a power
that is delegated to the federal
government this is a power for states to
decide in south dakota we're going to be
free and we're going to make sure that
we don't overstep our authority so we
will take action my legal team is
already working and we will defend and
protect our people from this unlawful
mandate
it seemed like when he said instead of
encouraging people to get vaccinated and
mask up talking about governors
obviously republican they're ordering
mobile morgues
wow
joe biden is that the same guy that said
he'd never do this because that would
make him a big hypocrite wouldn't it
he is a huge hypocrite he said he create
jobs and he's destroying jobs he's he
said he'd love america and protect us
and then he makes friends with the
taliban and compromises our southern
border it's unbelievable to me what he
is doing i knew he'd wreck this country
that's why i campaigned so hard for
president trump i had no idea anyone
alive could wreck this country as fast
as joe biden is
yeah all right governor we're going to
watch your case in the case of these
other governors very closely uh and
thank you so much for being with us